THANK YOU
FOR COMING IN
WITH YOUR ASSOCIATES.
I KNOW THIS IS HARD TO HEAR,
BUT...
WE NEED TO MAKE
SOME SERIOUS DECISIONS
ABOUT YOUR MOTHER'S HEALTH.
LET'S BE HONEST.
SHE IS GETTING ON
IN YEARS.
- OH, SNAP.
OKAY, I SEE HOW IT IS.
I SEE HOW IT I--
WELL, YO MAMA SO OLD,
HER LAST NAME IS "OSAURUS."
[laughter]
- BOOM!
- N-NO, MR. LOUIS,
IT WASN'T AN INSULT.
I--I WAS JUST SAYING
THAT YOUR MOTHER'S CONDITION
IS DETERIORATING, UH,
BECAUSE SHE'S GETTING OLDER.
- OH, SEE THAT'S COLD, THOUGH.
THAT'S A COLD ONE, OKAY.
OKAY, I SEE HOW IT IS.
HEY, Y'ALL.
YO MAMA SO OLD,
IN HER HISTORY CLASS,
THEY JUST WROTE DOWN
WHAT THEY WAS DOING.
[laughter]
HE'S TALKING ABOUT--
CH-CH-CH-CH-CH--
CH-CH-CH-CH-CH-CH-CH-CH-CH-CH--
[laughs]
- MR. LOUIS,
THIS ISN'T AN INSULT CONTEST.
NOT ONLY
IS YOUR MOTHER ELDERLY,
BUT ALSO HER ABILITY
TO WALK
IS CURRENTLY BEING AFFECTED
BY HER WEIGHT.
- OH.
- OOH.
- SEE, OKAY.
IT JUST GOT REAL.
- NO, I'M NOT INSULTING HER.
I'M TRYING TO TELL YOU THE--
- YO MAMA IS SO FAT, WHEN
SHE GO TO THE MOVIE THEATER,
BITCH SITTING
NEXT TO EVERYONE.
- EXCUSE ME. EXCUSE ME.
- LISTEN TO ME, OKAY?
YOUR MOTHER NEEDS
TO MANAGE HER WEIGHT,
OR THERE CAN BE
SOME REAL PROBLEMS.
- OH...KAY!
ALL RIGHT.
OH, YEAH.
YO MAMA IS SO FAT, SHE NEED
A LATITUDE AND LONGITUDE NUMBER
TO FIND
HER OWN ASS[bleep].
- OH!
[laughter]
- LOOK AT HIS FACE! YEAH!
LOOK AT HIS FACE!
- AH! AH!
- GIVE IT TO HIM.
- OH.
- GIVE ME SOME.
- IT'S COORDINATES, SON.
COORDINATES.
NOW WHO'S THE DOCTOR?
- I AM THE DOCTOR.
MR. LOUIS, I AM.
AND IT IS MY JOB TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOUR MOTHER
IS GETTING THE CARE
THAT SHE NEEDS.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE WOMAN
WHO TOOK CARE
OF YOU YOUR WHOLE LIFE.
THE LEAST YOU CAN DO
IS TAKE CARE OF HER
IN HER OLD AGE
AND TAKE THIS SERIOUSLY!
- I'M SORRY.
- I'M SORRY
THAT I LOST MY TEMPER.
- NO, REALLY, DOCTOR.
I GUESS...
I WAS JUST JOKING AROUND
BECAUSE I KNOW HER CONDITION
IS REALLY SERIOUS.
AND...I DON'T KNOW,
I GUESS HUMOR
IS THE ONLY WAY
I CAN REALLY DEAL WITH IT, UH--
[sighs]
I JUST KNOW
THAT SHE'S SAID SO MANY TIMES
SHE DOESN'T WANT
ANYTHING INVASIVE DONE.
- REALLY?
I WAS NOT AWARE OF THAT.
UM, THAT'S INTERESTING,
BECAUSE SHE DID NOT MENTION THAT
TO ME IN OUR
PREVIOUS CONVERSATION...
'COURSE IT WAS DIFFICULT
TO HEAR HER
WITH MY [bleep]
IN HER MOUTH.
SNAP, MR. LOUIS.
OH, SNAP.
NOW LET'S TALK
ABOUT THE PROCEDURE.